three words fill drive fight if
minecraft and World of Tanks got down
and dirty they'd name their love child's
Robocraft robo pray off tap back into
your childhood dig up those Lego skills
and put them to the test this MMO robot
vehicle shooter will make your dream
babies come back to life start in the
garage and tamper with one of the
pre-made vehicles choose one of three
ways to travel drive hover fly or hell
don't do anything at all just build a
block and let those stupid butt heads
come to you just remember stock yours up
with turrets alright time to battle here
we go oh yeah oh yeah okay you guys want
to go let's scrap this sample and start
from scratch
I present to you the sauce screw these
lasers I'm rocking plasma Oh what's up
oh you too mmm
well barely made it out of that one I
think my rotors could use some
protection back to the drawing board
okay let's cover up these blades with
some stronger armor in fact let's soup
up this whole Beach with armor look out
boys coming through it okay let's party
okay look alive all right ultimate the
sauce is a little heavy well let's lose
some of that baby weight and since we've
leveled up let's hit the tech treat by
some tier two rotors level two plasma
guns bronze plated armor and let's go
ahead and treat ourselves a couple more
plasma guns ought to do it it's on now
[ __ ]
this a floating ball that's cute you're
cute
downtown who's next
Oh what's a HUP where you going little
buddy this sauce is the boss oh yeah
this guy knows what's up oh no dude get
up all right I will
man this sauce is like too good so let's
take a look at some other bodacious BOTS
the land speeder all right
not too shabby little weak the spinning
pillar no okay here we go the
steamroller steamroller to point out oh
yeah let's roll all right steamroller
3.0 okay let's get a little more
creative here how about the Magnum you
guys feel lucky well kill you punks oh
you do okay let's turn it up a notch I
present to you the death diamond
I guess diamonds aren't forever what
else can we build what else can build so
smoke sorry about that excuse me comin
through
oh no my stock someone help okay round
two look out here we go all right
I think the shaft on this craft is a
little top-heavy
let's low rad this dude nice shop
Johnson here we go
sliding the home headshot
again this is free to play people
matchmaking is quick leveling up is a
cinch battling is a blast you can't go
wrong here try it out
[Music]